what do you let me add you some bro what
[ __ ] you're the other realest
[ __ ] I have in hip-hop that I've
encountered as a human being yes sir
what what do you make of like this whole
entire Takashi thing man
um because a cons doing it locked up
remix what I'm like I'm just wondering
what your perspective is like I know
what it is I know what your perspective
is but at the same time like I feel like
it's before too long we're gonna see
certain rappers doing records with them
like I feel like the Tauri features
inevitable what's gonna happen
cuz I know that those guys were like
actual friends before all this happens
yeah you know fake [ __ ] always link
and you guys did Mexico together so what
the [ __ ] that means
how about I'm saying is like I said fake
[ __ ] always lean what are your
thoughts on the whole situation cuz I do
think that there's two separate
conversations there's the entertainment
conversation and then there's the you
know the real street conversation
factual I mean you know you name
somebody that probably would do a song
with him I would you know if I was the
think of attending cuz that wouldn't do
a song Takashi's that I was at yeah Tori
it would be one of them but uh you know
what man I don't hold [ __ ] like that
to the same standard as you hold
yourself to not at all or people realize
rx9 and Tori like young [ __ ] like that
I'll need the whole team [ __ ] to light
street neither standards because the
[ __ ] ain't Street [ __ ] you know then
like a con I love a con
shabbu but no I don't respect that move
of course not [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mother you know that I mean
constant records like it's like there's
convict records or whatever I don't give
a [ __ ] what it is but you know my
perspective is I you know I don't
respect that move you know me and like
you know she and you know me and
Buddha's ate dinner together not too
long ago and they've had [ __ ]
Delilah's but I love a fam I love it
but no okay and I might make a move and
I might make a move that you don't
respect but that'll mean that when you
see me that is beef No
exactly I don't respect that move not a
nothing no [ __ ] way
you know I mean so it is what it is but
you you do you think y'all [ __ ] richer
than me so whatever y'all doing you know
I mean like is some rich native [ __ ] so
I'm not knocking you out me you think
anybody who works with that guy there's
just like a stain on him okay so you did
because because he was like you said you
the standards are all different from
overall every [ __ ] to the same standard
as me because every make like a little
Dickie does the song with six nine you
be like yeah whatever it's little Dickie
like you know but if it's it but if it's
[ __ ] make it Meeks not doing it
wouldn't do that no of course not but
I'm saying like as far as standards it's
like there's certain there's certain
artists there you'd be like I do what
you do everything I'm gonna do what you
do cuz I don't hold every auto hold none
of these [ __ ] to the same standard as
me you know and I had to learn that
personally cuz that first I used to do
that I our size to be like man what the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh what the [ __ ]
by the way I know I'd be like ah you
know I mean I'm gonna to me unless you
like do some like I'll do a song with
damn near any negative to you know I
mean like less you do like some like six
nine [ __ ] or some r.kelly [ __ ] then I
want for the lines in the sand yeah
exactly that's it like I said I won't do
a song with six nine and I won't do a
song with our Kelly right now Freight
bills 96 me running or Kelly what should
remain tails
what are Chi cago - Gary [ __ ] what
Chicago Gary your figures good best of
all worlds
[ __ ] but now best above [ __ ] but now
kales a big I gotta say [ __ ] you dude